and our economics and data editor Ed
Conway is here with me Ed Sam's just
given us sort of politics of all this
um what about the economics yeah there's
I mean there's quite a lot here and
actually after after we talk about some
of the big numbers there's there's also
the question of what's happening in
markets at the moment which which kind
of impinges on this budget story not as
not as kind of badly as it did uh at the
time of the mini budget but let's just
kind of remind ourselves of some of kind
of the big story here and the big story
is that the economy isn't necessarily
quite as in as quite as bad a place as
it was last time around what we're
looking at here is the level of GDP
growth so it's kind of the size of the
economy total national income when this
line is going up we're all getting
better off and this is how things lose
before the pandemic okay so March 2020
before the you know the impact of
lockdowns and so on that line was going
up and up and up then of course we all
know we had the pandemic this went down
enormously but it started to kind of
gradually go up and last time around I
said last time last nov remember that's
what was expected now look at this line
and look how it changes this time look
it's slightly higher and what does that
mean well first of all the dip isn't
quite so much we don't have a fully
blown recession but we do have something
like a flat lining and then the line
starts to go up
um but here's the thing that's the obr
the office of budget responsibility
forecast we've just heard about today
um other people think things could
actually be worse so this is what the
bank of England thinks is more likely a
flatlining that lasts not just for a few
quarters but all the way out into the
future that would be quite depressing
and that would be a big blow for the UK
economy in terms of kind of where the
money is being spent well this was
actually a bigger budget than a lot of
people expected I mean some people are
looking at and saying it's kind of
relatively boring by the standards of
recent budgets but a lot of money was
leaving always due to leave the treasury
each year going on for the next few
years what this is showing you is what's
known as the scorecard and anything
these bars basically represent how much
how much money billions of pounds is
going out of the exchequer into people's
pockets and if you just kind of break it
down little bit okay so we're breaking
it down by the different things that the
government is spending money on so for
instance around there you've actually
got the uh the spending on energy bills
so that the energy price guarantee that
kicks in uh initially doesn't actually
cost that much because Energy prices are
quite low at the moment but by Far and
Away the biggest bit here is the blue
swathe of These Bars which is full
expensing so basically the government in
2024-25 spending about 10 billion pounds
ensuring that businesses can offset some
of their money spent on investment
against their tax bills it sounds a
little bit technical but that
potentially leads to more money invested
in the future that's the promise at
least but here's the thing it only lasts
for three years and then it tails off
and as a result of that you're not
necessarily seeing strong growth in the
future
um you've also got for instance child
care so those Child Care Provisions
about kind of four or five billion
pounds on that and then pensions it's
quite a small slice that's being spent
on pensions we're just looking at total
spending overall spending here but of
course very controversial because it's
going to better off people that pensions
increasing the the lifetime allowance
now I mentioned that there is a story
right now that's kind of emerging
outside of the UK which is what's
happening in markets Credit Suisse which
is a Swiss bank having big trouble at
the moment and part of the consequence
of that is that people are getting very
nervous about the economy and they're
betting that central banks around the
world including the bank of England
aren't going to be raising interest
rates quite so far so just to give you a
sense of what we're talking about here
last August this was the expectation for
interest rates you might remember these
charts from the time of the mini budget
because that was very low then the mini
budget sent it very high up to 6.5
percent and then things started to
improve so by last week the expected
rate and this is all just forecasts for
where interest rates are going and it
matters because that's part of the the
cost of living issue that we're going
through at the moment rates were
expected to Peak at 4.75 percent we're
all feeling that if you have a mortgage
you're certainly feeling that or you
will be if you refix quite soon but
here's what's interesting because people
are so nervous about what's going on in
financial markets they're ratcheting
down their expectation for what's going
to happen to interest rates just look at
this today
the expectation is the interest rates
are only going to Peak I say only by the
standards of last few years that's quite
high but compared with recently only at
4.1 percent some people think there may
not be any more increases in interest
rates now I know that's not a budget
story but these are the kind of noises
off that the chancellor is going to have
to deal with if not you know within this
budget then in the next few years and
and charts like this and numbers like
this affect people's lives just as much
you know some would say more than what
we've got in the actual budget itself
very very briefly I mean how do you know
or how does anyone know what happening
what's happening now on the stock
markets is due to Credit Suisse and so
forth and the banking or budget or and
how I'm going to come and sit down I
mean the the main difficult to tell it's
well it or in this case in this in
what's happening I think in this case
it's it's relatively clear in the same
way that it was kind of it was quite
clear last time around that there was so
much nervous nervousness about the mini
budget that that kind of contributed to
markets falling today though Mark
looking at the ftse it it's formed by
more today than it did after the mini
budget and that's not because of people
watching the you know that's got nothing
to do with it and normally to be honest
with you we talk about this being a bit
more like a normal budget normally UK
budgets Don't Rock the markets that was
an aberration but the markets are being
rocked by the fact that people are
really nervous not necessarily we're
talking about financial crisis but we
are talking about certain Banks which
are really affected by higher interest
rates and all sorts of other things
Credit Suisse is in is in real trouble
if you look at the share price and yeah
that that's nerving people out a lot
which is what leads to charts like that